foreign
ly used survey questions that I'm going
to base a lot of what I talk about
evidence on is asking people overall how
satisfied they are with their life these
days or words to that effect you know
kind of varies from survey to survey but
that's the kind of essence of the
question how satisfied are you with your
life
on a scale between zero and ten
in survey data typically the averages
are seven point something
right they kind of you know change a
little bit over time
um and in the UK over the last decades
you know sort of 0.2.3 here and there
but they're kind of around the seven and
a half seven point seven seven point
sixes three if we look at tens of
thousands of people over decades
ask them that question about how
satisfied they are with their life and
then find out all sorts of other stuff
about them
what other stuff about them has the
biggest effects on the scores they give
the first thing to say is an academic is
that we we always caveat what we say
with
we're trying to establish causal
mechanisms right I want to show
something causal about the effects of
jobs health housing income on happiness
I don't want a correlation
because that correlation could also mean
that happier people have better jobs
nicer houses and so on right what I want
is a causal effect I want to I want to
establish the treatment effect of having
more money or or a better job or nicer
house Better Health on people's
happiness and it's hard to establish
causal mechanisms without randomized
controlled trials right what I'd love to
be able to do is to randomize
people to different income levels or to
different health status
money doesn't make people happy unless
you're poor poverty makes people
miserable and I'm now going to start
drawing attention to what I think is
then going to be the fundamental thing
that I want to say to you which is about
the role of attention
the reason part of the reason why the
lack of money makes people miserable is
because they're paying attention to not
having enough money they're paying
attention to whether they can pay the
bills feed the kids
service to debt it's a very attention
seeking condition
as people get richer it's then it
becomes truer that money doesn't make
people happy when you get to the average
levels of income or a little bit above
the relationship then between happiness
and income becomes very flat
because largely because you ceased to be
paying attention to something in a
negative way
interestingly some of the evidence
suggests and this is kind of a little
bit
um unclear or the evidence is mixed I
should say that
at very high levels of income happiness
levels might start to fall again
and I think this is again due to an
attentional phenomena
that you then start paying attention to
money
have I got the right stocks and shares
do I have the right portfolio have we
bought a big enough house
all these things that draw attention to
themselves not always in positive ways
and I think the income when you when say
how people should interpret evidence on
income is that if anyone
watches football or actually any sport
where you have a referee often people
will say the refs had a good game
because he or she wasn't seen right so
they didn't really notice the ref in the
game and I think that's what income is
like for us or ought to be like for us
right when you're not paying attention
to it
you probably have just enough money
when you're paying attention to it
you're probably not paying attention to
it in good ways certainly not when
you're poor maybe not even when you're
rich
so that's income largely dealt with but
the fundamental point I want to make is
that when you say anything does anything
make someone happy I say well it depends
on how much attention you pay it
so when uh people have talked about the
determinants of Happiness they talked
about the role of income in explaining
happiness
that's a bit like trying to explain how
many widgets a firm makes by just
looking at the inputs of land labor and
so on but there's a production process
in the middle yeah that converts those
inputs into the outputs
you can produce more widgets by having
more input and also by having a more
efficient production process
there's a production process of
happiness that has been largely absent
from our academic you know kind of
conversations and I talk a lot about in
happiness by Design which is the
production process of attention
right all of those inputs convert into
happiness through the role of attention
whether and in what ways and for how
long whether it's positively negative
and so on the attention you pay to it
determines how much that input affects
your out your outcome of Happiness just
like the production process of inputs
producing the number of widgets
so all the answers to all the questions
will be it depends on how much attention
is paid to it and in what ways
and I think income is one of those
things you don't want to be paying
attention to
health is a fundamental determinant of
people's happiness mental health in
particular much more than physical
health
why because by and large not always and
everywhere people get used to physical
functioning problems in a way that they
don't to mental health problems right
mental health problems continually draw
attention to themselves
right if you've got a if you were to
have a injury that made you less mobile
Enterprise that wasn't very painful in
drawing attention to itself you would
adapt relatively quickly to that but
mental health problems anxiety
depression you don't get used to them
you don't get less depressed after a
year than you were after a day
it constantly draws attention to itself
and if we're going to use happiness data
to inform policy that's not what I'm
here to talk about today then we would
give much greater priority to mental
health conditions than we currently do
because of the constant
attention-seeking nature of those
conditions
housing quality how it's interesting we
don't have much on housing quality we
have we have on whether you rent or own
lots of data on that some data showing
that whether people are some data
sometimes showing that that people that
own their own homes are happier than
those that aren't but not always and
everywhere
what else there was jobs I mean
unemployment is actually one of the
biggest and longest lasting effects on
people's happiness
again if you're thinking about policy
interventions then mitigating the harm
of unemployment unemployment scars even
when you're back in work again
and we think that's because again a kind
of intentional phenomenon around
security right if I've lost my job once
I can lose it again even though I'm now
back in work so from a standard economic
metric you've got someone backing work
everything's fine they're earning more
money but from a well-being perspective
they're less happy than they would have
been had they not lost their job in the
first place
I would advise you in Surprise this is
going to be some sort of self-help class
um if you're thinking about quitting
something or doing something or you know
leaving a job leaving a partner even
that's where it gets a little dodgy um
do it
because because
of our ability to make sense of stuff
um actually I'll ask you to put your
hands about something else hands up if
you're now with somebody as a you know
as your partner boyfriend girlfriend
whatever wife husband who's less good
than someone you were with previously
go and be honest
no no one well yeah this really turns to
whether you make it public or not that's
a really uh of course but even in
private even in private most people
won't think they are
because we have an amazing capacity for
cognitive dissonance we're able to
interpret and understand things and
explain things that's the key part to
adaptation is explanation
and when you have uncertainty you can't
explain uncertainty there's no
resolution to uncertainty through
explanation
so you have to resolve the uncertainty
and then you can move on
it's part of the reason why we see in
the happiness data around marriage and
separation and then when you get the
divorce is that there's an uptick after
the separation ends because the
separation is an attention seeking phase
where we get back together again won't
we divorce is final done move on we have
an extraordinary ability to get over
stuff in ways that we're not often able
to forecast very very well that's uh
good things and bad things
but the next the next layer
beyond the conditions and circumstances
is
um ourselves and identities our
personalities our expectations
the kinds of people we are whether we're
introvert extrovert
um whether we have construct identities
and stories a lot of our lives are lived
in narratives and stories about
ourselves and about our lives what role
do they play in in our happiness we
don't have actually lots of good data on
many of these identities it's much it's
much easier to ask people questions
about their income and about their
health or it's just been more routine to
do that over time than it has to ask
them questions about
um themselves their attitudes beliefs
and so on
um
in the personality and I think people
are familiar with the personality
uh Dimensions you can you can think of
the there's a kind of big five
um that you might think of as ocean
which is openness conscientiousness
extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism
uh unsurprisingly neurotics are less
happy
extroverts report being happier than
introverts
we don't have very much good data but of
course how we how we deal with our
conditions are now and how we deal with
our circumstances will be a function of
our expectations and the kind of people
we are
um
we have you know some data showing this
would be unsurprising that if you move
up the social Mobility ladder there are
some small gains but moving down the
social Mobility ladder there are
significant losses
right much greater than the gains from
moving up right moving down generally
is a bad thing right to see your income
Fall by 10 compared to rise by 10 is
much much more painful I want to then
move on to the next layer which is what
we do right and when we start measuring
happiness in the ways that I advocate in
happiness by Design which is much more
experiential much more about asking
people how happy they are when they're
going about their daily lives right not
when they're reflecting on how satisfied
they are with it whatever that answer
might mean in the two seconds and it
takes them to answer it
but when we when we drill down into
finding out what people do who they're
with and what they're thinking about in
their minds then I think we get a better
and more rich rich measure of the flow
of experience
um and there's anyone who's seen
Happiness by Design knows that I talk
about pleasure and purpose as the twin
sets of experiences we're not only
interested in being happy in a fun sense
but we also want to be happy in a
fulfillment worthwhileness meaningful
sense
unhappy lives are ones that contain the
right balance between those two things
but when we look at the activities that
people engage in
most of the evidence is is really
obvious but overlooked in the sense that
everyone when I when I say the following
things to you you're going to say no
Professor the lse is telling me
that
um and I'll say well why aren't you
doing more of it then right and again I
need to be careful because there's
significant variation across individuals
right any anyone who says there's a
one-size-fits-all approach to happiness
is probably sending you snake oil so my
one size fits-all approach to happiness
is to say that listen to more music
I mean the the evidence on music is is
overwhelming I mean it literally lights
the whole brain up
um in ways that no other stimulus can
and not only at the time that you're
listening to the music but but for some
time they're they're thereafter listen
to music that you enjoy obviously that
not someone else forces you to listen to
um
like your parents or something
um I'm trying to get my kids to like the
music it's really hard
um I will win
um
in the end
um so they can be their authentic selves
uh
what was I talking about right yes so
music
um laughter that's a I mean that's a
really it's really interesting that we
can prescribe laughter on the NHS now
social prescriptions for laughter is
kind of good on good good on the one
hand that it's evidence-based but a bit
sad on the other hand that you need a
prescription to laugh obvious but
overlooked right we're not building it
into our daily daily lives and daily
experiences
um going Outdoors
being around nature biophilia it's
called that's you know that's kind of
good for us even in ways that we might
not predict
having new experiences that's that's the
reason why time passes so slowly for
kids
because every day is a new experience to
them
when you get to our ages if it takes a
same it's like waiting for death
um uh well yeah I've still I've still
got I still have to come to death don't
worry um uh I'll finish finish on death
at the end
um leave you with a really positive note
to go away
um
help other people
I cannot impress upon you enough how
selfish helping other people is
and how we should be celebrating that
selfishness much more than we do and
actually this is where we do have good
randomized control evidence but if you
tap into the personal benefits of
pro-sociality you get more of it for
longer
if you draw attention to volunteers the
benefits that they're going to get from
volunteering they help other people for
more and for longer
and yet we have this narrative around
charity of it being something that is a
hierarchy that at the top of this
hierarchy is the sort of
self-flagellation the cleanse of any
personal benefit altruism
I think that's harmful it's harmful for
getting more pro-sociality
so being more transparent it's really
interesting that I can observe lots of
things about you right
um obviously age and race and so on but
also probably your income levels and
other other things but how generous you
are is something that's unobservable
right if we make it more transparent we
would get more of it
or in the description below or or visit
IAI dot TV for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas